the drug gangs of Rio de Janiero
like nothing I've ever seen before
they're much more like a militia or a
terrorist organization than any of the
gangs I have met across the world these
three a part of the security section of
one of the gangs the soldiers there are
a hundred of them they were sent to
check us out
the for meetings with more senior gang
leaders recent police raids have made
them jumpy a gang member was killed the
day before they're only wearing
balaclavas because of our cameras in
their neighborhood they openly deal
drugs and weapons without any fear but
during this interview they wanted to
stress they were part of a business a
business they say but cannot be broken
there at the government the new
president has launched a war on the
factions do you get attacked by the
police often it's an elemental my psyche
I gave you happening game to do I think
you should care in the favelas the slums
of Rio are home to a hugely
sophisticated and lucrative crime
business its natural home is in these
back streets but in reality it spreads
throughout society the money generated
by the gangs is used to buy people and
protection the key to it all is money
and in the gang the money man is king
after months of negotiation I was
finally allowed to beat the man with the
money it just completed a pickup was
preparing to do his accounts the ward of
notes is worth about 10,000 pounds he
picks up the same amount every two days
this gang and it's not a big one is
clearing 1 million 800 pounds the
government here is making a big thing of
attacking the gangs but the money man
insists corruption will beat any
legitimate efforts to destroy them he
tells me that when he is bulk buying
drugs the dealers are often the police
themselves selling confiscated drugs he
takes his guards assault rifle
it's from Paraguay with a 100-round drum
magazine we don't go to Paraguay to get
it what he means is that it's being
brought in legitimately then sold
everyone who assist is involved first
pass the sacrament the psychologically
okay boom Monica's gonna go sing before
that - policia people so all of
society's song the USSR the Brazilian
government is promising to win the war
on organized crime in the favelas the
gangs have always said they won't be
beaten because too many people have too
much to lose
innocent people caught in the middle may
hope that a change is coming but with
corruption like it is it doesn't seem
very likely very soon
Stuart Ramsey Sky News Rio de Janeiro